a funeral was held in italy this week
for a teenage boy who was killed by a
car driven by a u.s service woman the
air force member was arrested for
allegedly driving drunk at the time
seth doan reports from portia italy
northeast of venice
good morning this is the intersection
where that deadly accident took place
the small memorial here does not quite
reflect the overwhelming grief we've
witnessed
[Music]
they gathered to mourn that life cut
short fifteen-year-old giovanni zanier
youth filled this church in northeastern
italy late last week
it was solidarity and sadness
zanier was struck by a car early sunday
driven by american service member julia
bravo she had a blood alcohol level
roughly four times the legal limit she's
stationed at the nearby aviano u.s air
force base where she met with her lawyer
aldo massaroot
he told us his 20 year old client who's
from texas is currently under house
arrest in her apartment at the base
what
is her defense this
this young boy has been killed
a consultant to reconstruct the incident
he told us adding a toxicology expert is
also needed
determining whether the alcohol level is
really that high is crucial he noted
since penalties increase as blood
alcohol levels rise
this incident is reminding folks here of
another deadly one in 1998
a plane from the same base clipped a
cable car line killing 20 people the air
crew was repatriated to the u.s and
ultimately acquitted
troops in nato bases including this one
are governed by an agreement signed back
in the 1950s which lays out jurisdiction
if crimes are committed by those
stationed here in this case italy has
the right to try the service woman but
the u.s could ask for her to be
extradited
this family wants the trial to take
place in italy fabio gasparini a lawyer
for the victim's family told us they
would like to follow this situation
closely and understand what's going on
roses were laid on the boy's coffin and
balloons were released as loved ones
turned to the heavens for relief
the investigation into exactly what
happened here is expected to go on for
months but lawyers tell us that here in
italy if someone is convicted of killing
someone and driving with that level of
blood alcohol in their system they could
face eight to 12 years in prison
for cbs saturday morning seth doan for
chia italy